>> Greg: IN THE WORLD OF FAKE
NEWS WE KNOW LONGER HAVE TO
WORRY ABOUT HOAXES, WE HAVE TO
DEAL WITH HOAX HOAXES, FRIDAY
WHEN RESIDENT TERM CALLED THE
DEMS ATTEMPT TO POLITICIZE THE
CORONAVIRUS A HOAX, HOW DID THE
MEDIA PORTRAY THAT?
THAT HE WAS CALLING THE VIRUS A
HOAX.
KICKING IT OFF WITH THIS.
"REMEMBER THIS MOMENT.
A TRUMP IN SOUTH CAROLINA CALLED
THE CORONAVIRUS A HOAX."
POLITICO PICKED IT UP WITH THIS
HEADLINE "BIDEN’S LAST TRUMP FOR
CALLING THE CORONAVIRUS A HOAX,"
IT FLEW THROUGH DESPERATE
DEMOCRATIC CANDIDATES, MIKE
BLOOMBERG TRUMPING THE LIE, EVEN
THOUGH ANYONE WHO READ THE
ACTUAL QUOTE COULD SEE IT WAS
B.S.
BUT THE MEDIA HOPES THAT OUR
LAZINESS WILL HELP THE HACKS GET
AWAY WITH MISINFORMATION.
AND IF YOU POINT OUT THE LIES,
CNN’S HALL MONITORS WILL ACCUSE
YOU OF POLITICIZING IT.
I KNOW YOU ARE, BUT WHAT MY
SCHOOL OF DEBATE MET WITH
LAUGHTER.
BUT THERE IS HOPE AS REPORTERS
CALL OUT THESE FAKE NEWS
VIRUSES.
AFTER BLOOMBERG BLASTED TRUMP
FOR CALLING IT A HOAX, REPORTER
STOPPED HIM.
>> I FIND IT INCOMPREHENSIBLE
THAT THE PRESIDENT WOULD DO
SOMETHING AS INANE AS CALLING IT
A HOAX, WHICH HE DID LAST NIGHT
IN SOUTH CAROLINA.
>> HE SAID THAT THE DEMOCRATS
MAKING SO MUCH OF IT IS A
DEMOCRATIC HOAX, NOT THAT THE
VIRUS WAS A HOAX.
>> THIS IS UP TO THE SCIENTIST
AND THE DOCTORS AS TO WHETHER
THERE IS A PROBLEM.
>> Greg: HE WAS NOW THE ONLY
ONE, OTHERS ON TWITTER CALLED
OUT THE LIE WHICH FORCES THE
MEDIA TO FIND ANOTHER PATH TO
HAMMER THOSE THEY HATE.
THAT’S A PROBLEM WITH THE
MEDIA’S BIAS.
IT’S NOT SO MUCH CONTAGIOUS AS
IT IS INCURABLE.
THE BEST DEFENSE, WASHING YOUR
HANDS OF THEM.
>> Jesse: LIKE WHAT YOU DID
THERE APPEAR TO >> Greg: THAT
WAS A LANDING OF A LINE.
WASHING YOUR HANDS OF THEM.
I SHOULD JUST LEAVE RIGHT NOW.
I SHOULD JUST GO HOME AND GET TO
MY HOUSE EARLY AND HAVE RIBS.
ALONE.
IN THE DARK.
EMILY, WHAT DO YOU THINK?
YOU KNOW FACEBOOK IDENTIFIED THE
POLITICO STORY AS FAKE NEWS.
THAT’S PRETTY COOL, FACEBOOK.
>> Emily: IT IS TROUBLING THAT
WE ARE HEARING THE GUY’S PARROT
THE SAME THINGS DEBUNKED WHEN IT
IS SO EASY.
AND IN THE FACE OF SOMETHING
THAT HAS THE POTENTIAL FOR A
REALLY BIG DEAL ON THIS COUNTRY
FOR THEM TO BE OBSESSING OVER
THE PRESIDENT’S RESPONSE.
THE MARKET HAS ITS WORST WEEK IN
12 YEARS AND SHOWS YOU WHAT
HUMANS TAKE SERIOUSLY.
IT’S NOT IMPEACHMENT TRIALS.
IT’S NOT OH, MY GOSH, COLLUSION.
ALL OF THIS STUFF RAN DOWN OUR
THROATS AS OPPOSED TO THE NEXT
ARMAGEDDON, IT IS A PUBLIC
HEALTH SITUATION.
SO TO ME IT KIND OF BRINGS UP
AND HIGHLIGHTS WHAT IS IMPORTANT
AND CERTAINLY THE MEDIA’S
COVERAGE AND THE OBSESSION WITH
THE HOAX COMMENT IS OFF THE MARK
MARK.
>> Greg: THEY ALSO SAID THAT
TRUMP WAS MUZZLING --
AND HE PUSHED BACK ON THAT.
>> Dana: DO WE HAVE THE SOUND?
A >> Greg: DO WE HAVE SOUND?
HOW DARE YOU.
WE DO NOT HAVE SOUND, DANA.
THIS IS NOT "THE DAILY
BRIEFING."
>> Dana: I LIKE THAT HE
STEPPED UP TO THE PODIUM TO SAY,
LET ME BE VERY CLEAR, I WAS NOT
MUZZLED.
AND WHAT HE IS EXPLAINING MAKES
A LOT OF SENSE.
WHEN THE PRESIDENT PUT
VICE PRESIDENT MIKE PENCE IN
CHARGE, HE SAID LET’S TAKE HALF
A MOMENT TO LOOK AT ALL OF THE
THINGS THAT WE ARE DOING AND ALL
THE DIFFERENT PARTS OF
GOVERNMENT AND GET ONE COHESIVE
UNIT SO THAT UIGHURS SPEAKING TO
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
THAT MADE A LOT OF SENSE TO ME.
WHEN IT COMES TO IF YOU ARE ON
THE CAMPAIGN TRAIL AND YOU HEAR
SOMETHING THAT SOUNDS JUST TOO
GOOD TO BE TRUE, AND THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP SAID THAT YOU
WANT TO RUN WITH, CHECK
YOURSELF.
BECAUSE IT USUALLY IS NOT TRUE.
AND THEN YOU LOOK FOOLISH.
>> Greg: JESSE, SHOULD THE
MEDIA APOLOGIZE TO YOU?
>> Jesse: [LAUGHS]
I EXPECT THE CHINESE TO
APOLOGIZE BEFORE THE MEDIA, YOU
ARE EXCITED, WEREN’T YOU?
>> Greg: JUST THE ENDING.
WASHING YOUR HANDS OF THEN WAS A
NICE TURN OF PHRASE.
I ONLY GET ONE OF THOSE A YEAR.
>> Jesse: I THINK YOU DO MORE
THAN THAT, BUT CONGRATS, WELL
SAID.
THE PRESIDENT HAS HANDLED THE
VIRUS VERY WELL.
ONLY TWO THINGS THAT YOU CAN
CRITICIZE THE GUY FOR IF YOU
LOOK AT THE CDC, THEY HAD THE
CONTAMINATION AT THE TEST SITE
AND GOT THE THIS GETS OUT TOO
SLOWLY, AND TO RELEASING A WOMAN
WHO WAS INFECTED THAT SHE HAD
BEEN TESTED POSITIVE, THAT WAS A
MISTAKE.
THOSE ARE SUB NOTES HAVE ISSUES
THAT YOU CAN SAY YOU BETTER
CLEAN THAT UP.
AND THEY HAVE CLEANED IT UP.
BUT TO SAY THAT THE PRESIDENT IS
LYING.
IF THAT HE HAS MUZZLING DOCTORS,
TO SAY THAT HE IS CUTTING THE
CDC IS RIDICULOUS.
TO SAY THAT THE TASK FORCE IS
TOO WHITE OR MIKE PENCE IS TOO
RELIGIOUS TO RUN IT IS
RIDICULOUS.
THEY SAY THAT MIKE PENCE WILL
PARADE THE VIRUS AWAY.
HE IS NOT EQUIPPED TO HANDLE
THIS.
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" RUNS TWO
COLUMNS COMPARING THE PRESIDENT
OF THE VIRUS.
PAUL KRUGMAN CELEBRATES THE DOWD
DROPPING.
"THE WASHINGTON POST"
ENCOURAGING DEMOCRATS TO MAKE A
POLITICALLY OUT OF THE VIRUS.
AND MY FAVORITE, CNN SAYS THAT
THE TRAVEL RESTRICTION THAT
TRUMP DID WAS RACIST AND WOULD
BACKFIRE, AND TODAY THEY PUT
THEIR OWN TRAVEL RESTRICTION ON
THEIR EMPLOYEES BECAUSE IT IS
SUCH A BIG DEAL.
SO, LOOK AT THE DOWEL, LOOK AT
THE STUDY THAT SAYS THAT THE
UNITED STATES IS THE BEST THE
BEST PREPARED COUNTRY TO HANDLE
THIS AND THE GALLUP POLL THAT
SAYS THAT 77% OF THE AMERICAN
PEOPLE ARE CONFIDENT IN THE
ADMINISTRATION’S RESPONSE TO THE
VIRUS.
>> Greg: SPEAKING OF CNN,
JUAN, THERE WAS A LOWER THIRD
THAT SAID CAN WE STOP THE
CORONAVIRUS OR BERNIE SANDERS?
SO IT WAS LIKE WHY WOULD THEY
PUT THAT TOGETHER?
>> Juan: I HAVE SOMETHING TO
SAY HERE, BECAUSE I THINK
EXACERBATING THE KIND OF
POLITICAL DIVIDE MAKES PEOPLE
LESS SAFE.
AND TO MY MIND, THE VIRUS IS
APOLITICAL.
IT WILL GET YOU NO MATTER WHERE
YOU ARE, RIGHT?
SO I THINK PEOPLE SEE THROUGH
THAT.
TO HAVE PEOPLE SEE THE VIRUS
THROUGH A PARTISAN LENS IS
DANGEROUS.
IT IS LIKE THAT AUNTIE BAXTER’S
WHO MADE THE THING SO POLITICAL.
THAT IS CRAZY AND REGRETTABLE.
SO I AGREE THAT THE PRESIDENT
DID NOT SAY THAT THE VIRUS WAS A
HOAX.
WHAT HE SAID WAS THE DEMOCRATS
OF THE WAY THAT THEY ARE TALKING
ABOUT IT AMOUNTS TO A HOAX, BUT
GUESS WHAT, A LOT OF PEOPLE AT
THAT RALLY INTERPRET IT AS THIS
MIGHT BE A HOAX.
AND I THINK THAT MEANT FOR THEM
THAT IT WAS LIKE, YOU KNOW WHAT,
WE HAVE NOTHING TO WORRY ABOUT.
>> Jesse: HOW DO YOU KNOW WHAT
PEOPLE THOUGHT AT THE RALLY?
>> Greg: MIND READING.
>> Juan: EXCUSE ME.
NO IT IS NOT.
BECAUSE YOU WATCH TERMS OF THE
CONSERVATIVE MEDIA ENVIRONMENT,
THE WEBSITES, THE TALK RADIO, IT
IS ALL, YOU DON’T HAVE ANYTHING
TO WORRY ABOUT.
THIS IS COMING FROM THE TRUMP
STATEMENT IT IS A HOAX.
AND YOU TALK ABOUT PEOPLE WHO
MISINTERPRET WHAT IT WAS, THEY
ARE INTERPRETING IT AS THE HOAX
IS >> Greg: SO IT WAS A RUSE
AT THE RALLY?
>> Juan: I AM TALKING ABOUT
MEDIA VOICES YOU CAN PUT NAMES
TO AND SAYING THAT THIS IS
DANGEROUS BECAUSE IT SHOULD BE
APOLITICAL FROM BOTH SIDES NOT
JUST ONE SIDE.
AMERICA, THE VIRUS WILL GET YOU
UNLESS YOU TAKE THE APPROPRIATE
STEPS TO PAY ATTENTION AND DON’T
GET EMOTIONAL AND WE TRUST OUR
LEADERS.
>> Greg: I THINK THE
POPULATION IS GETTING SMARTER
ABOUT TAKING REPORTING AT FACE
VALUE.
IN A WEIRD WAY THERE SKEPTICISM